[Music]
happy deathday is the story of a girl
named tree who would fit in just fine
with the plastics for Mean Girls
she lives that kind of life and
unfortunately her life is cut very short
when somebody dressed up in a baby mask
kills her then she wakes up the
following morning and realizes she's
living the same day over and over again
so she lives the same days over and over
again trying to figure out how to
eventually find this person who is
killing her at the end of this day and
hopefully reset her life this is a story
we've seen in various forms before
Groundhog Day obviously being the most
obvious one edge of tomorrow just this
year a film called before I fall had a
very similar storyline which I did see
but didn't review it was alright it was
enjoyable and this film follows
basically the same type of plot and so
in that way it can feel very old what
this film does differently though than
other horror films is that it's very
tongue-in-cheek in fact I wouldn't even
really call this a horror movie this is
honestly more of a comedy it felt like
Legally Blonde mixed with Mean Girls and
Groundhog Day and before I fall and edge
of tomorrow it felt like a whole bunch
of other movies mixed into one
but it's definitely a lot more
lighthearted than I expected going in
because I actually didn't watch any of
the trailers I had maybe seen a few
seconds of things here and there at a
movie theater but I never really pay
attention to the trailers I just knew
the concept and I didn't really expect
the film to be as light-hearted or as
enjoyable as it ended up being this is
by no means a great horror movie and I
would certainly not say it's a great
film happy deathday is a very commercial
movie it's a movie that a lot of
audiences are going to enjoy especially
young teens its pg-13 the violence is
very minimal and it's fun enough to
enjoy on a surface level and it actually
features some pretty good performances
namely by Jessica Roth and Ruby Modine
both of these actresses do a fantastic
job here the direction is also pretty
good I like the way Christopher Landon
who made this film who also wrote a lot
of the
Paranormal Activity movies and directed
Scouts guide to the zombie apocalypse I
like the way he blocks scenes his action
sequences his chase sequences are pretty
exciting they're good-looking this is a
well-directed movie a surprisingly well
directed movie actually
but the downfall of it is that it just
feels so much like other films
gratefully it is tongue-in-cheek enough
to actually acknowledge that a character
direct references Groundhog Day in this
movie when she tries to explain her
problem to a friend and so it's very
much so self-aware and it has a lot of
cheesy corny montages that are trying to
be funny and I didn't expect that I
honestly just thought it was a straight
horror movie going in with the concept
of reliving the same day over and over
again unfortunately though it does take
away from the scare factor because I
didn't find the film scary at all
there's a lot of overuse of jump scares
and they're very weak jump scare so if
you like jump scares you'll probably not
really find much to get out of these if
you can get past the first act which
features some really insufferable
characters because that's the route the
film takes which is also very cliched
the lead heroine is as I said she would
fit in just fine and Mean Girls and so
she's pretty rude to everyone and you're
like my god it's kind of hard to watch
her treat all of these people like trash
and it follows that unfortunately
cliched storyline where she has to
figure out how to be a better person and
she's reliving the same day over and
over again and so there really aren't
too many surprises here speaking of
surprises once you do learn who the
culprit is when you look back on the
film it doesn't really hold together
you're like I don't really know if that
makes sense but I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't at least slightly entertained by
this movie it plays with some genre
tropes that were used to seeing and it
has a little bit of a role reversal in
certain ways that I thought was pretty
clever
but at the same time it also gives in to
a lot of the cliches of the genre so
it's kind of a mixed bag I'm gonna give
happy deathday a C+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching Friday the
13th is coming up very soon I'm gonna
have a very special review of one of the
Friday the 13th movies I'm excited to
bring that to you guys thank you very
much
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]